hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his article what is philosophy as a
way of life john
sellers is going to introduce a number
of helpful
distinctions and contrasts and
one that he introduces very early on
in the paper is between the
as he calls it scientific conception
of philosophy and the humanistic
conception
of philosophy he also calls these two
competing
images of philosophy these are ways that
philosophers
understand what it is that their
activity and their discipline
is supposed to be doing so it's
providing you could say motivations
norms orientations and he calls
he says that these are two quite
different ways of thinking about
philosophy he also says let's be
clear neither of these labels are ideal
they'll work for present purposes
and he he also has two
figures in mind to bring up as examples
of this but we could multiply
many more as well so
as the representative of the scientific
conception of philosophy
aristotle and as the representative of
the humanistic conception of philosophy
socrates and this is kind of an
interesting
set to pick out not least
because of course there's a missing
figure between them
you know socrates is the teacher of
plato
and plato is the teacher although you
know later on
after aristotle's already done some
stuff on his own of
aristotle and we could ask well where
does where does plato himself
actually figure into this distinction
and i've got a few ideas about that that
i might give you
at the end of this in any case seller
says we can use these two
as prime examples and i think he's
right about this and he's going to in
some respects
differ from the person who's most famous
in the present for this phrase
philosophy is a way of life
pierre ado in saying that aristotle
actually does
represent something that perhaps is
distanced from philosophy as a way of
life and there's there's a few things
that we can say about that
after fleshing out the distinction as
well so he says let's begin with
socrates
in the apology plato has socrates say
that his principal concern
in his philosophical activity is a
desire to transform his way of life
uh he says there's a few passages that
stand out the first is when socrates
tries to describe his philosophical
mission
those who've read the apology of course
know that socrates
claimed that he had a divine mission
that the god had given them
this task of doing philosophy
by you know the oracle there's a whole
interesting story to be
told there but he says he presents it as
a duty to live as a philosopher
not just to think as a philosopher not
just to teach philosophy or to foster
philosophy
but to live to engage
in practice in the course
of a life in the relationships that he
has in the conversations
that he's going to carry out even in
gestures that perhaps
are not by themselves commun
communicative
but do convey something
so examining himself
and others um later in response to his
accusers who've condemned him to death
you say you've brought about my death
and the belief that through it you'll
be delivered from submitting the conduct
of your lives to criticism so
seller says this idea that the task at
hand is to examine
lives and it's not just examining your
own life
right it's not just navel gazing you
could say it's not just a trick for
narcissists who
spend more and more time on themselves
but also examining the lives of
others and to do so in a way that is not
just to
you know elevate yourself above them or
to
criticize them for the sake of
criticizing them but to
you know improve one's own life and
one's
the the life of those that one cares
about so that's a really central thing
this notion of focusing
on one's life on a coherent
pattern born out within the structure of
one's own
living so socrates
takes philosophy as an activity directed
at trying to figure out how to live well
subjecting our current life to
examination
here's where we get to the second
important point knowledge
is part of philosophy for somebody like
socrates as a matter of fact when you
look at the dialogues
plato's dialogues but also even those of
xenophon attaining knowledge is
something that
is desired is it desired solely for its
own
sake or is it desired in order to
to do something well the answer in the
case of philosophy is a way of life
is that knowledge is you could say
always
not necessarily practical but it has
practical implications and orientations
that's why you want to know things so
that you can
focus on what needs to be fixed what
needs to be improved what needs to be
done in order to live well
and sellers says the motivation is clear
socrates
wants to find out how to live well not
just for the sake of
knowing how to live well but because he
actually
wants to live well to enjoy a good life
whatever that may be
and this is a bit of a side note here
but there's a lot of people this is a
common theme in practical philosophy
there's a lot of people
who read and talk about philosophy and
we can extend
this further to like leadership and
self-help and
all sorts of other practical oriented
things and all they do is they read
about it they never actually
apply it they don't experiment with it
they don't see
whether it's going to do anything
aristotle himself talks about this in
the nicomachean ethics
as you know these these people who read
treatises of ethics and then they don't
do anything different so that's
that's knowledge that's not really
functional and that's not what socrates
is
is about
then seller says if we turn to aristotle
or
at least the aristotle of metaphysics i
think you could say this about
other books as well but the metaphysics
stands out in this respect
we find a different image of philosophy
he presents the task
of philosophy as uncovering and i would
say
understanding knowing the causes
and principles of things philosophy is
knowledge of the truth
but the it's not uh action oriented
truth
or we could say you know practical truth
it's theoretical truth right he says
there's practical knowledge that's
concerned with action
but in the metaphysics he identifies
philosophy or at least the best part of
philosophy
with theoretical knowledge and
prioritizes theoretical knowledge
over practical knowledge because it
deals with things that
are unchanging and that's you know
there's an interesting
story to tell there about why aristotle
makes that choice
even in the things where there is some
some focus on what
is changing it can be done for
for example human affairs right it can
be done in a way that's primarily
theoretical
rather than practical and and in
aristotle one of the problems
in his works is the hard split
between the practical which is just
about doing not about knowing
at least he says so and the theoretical
so there's this prioritization
of the theoretical modes of knowledge
and truth
over the practical and and you know this
is kind of a problem he also mentions
one other philosophy here he says the
parade
paradigmatic example of a philosopher
aristotle has in mind
is not socrates but instead thales
a you know physicist in in the early
sense
the man who fell down a well because he
was engrossed in studying the stars
they failed to look where he was going
and he says that you know granted
in the metaphysics he does aristotle
does say that
philosophy embraces theoretical
practical and productive questions but
he insists
that first philosophy that he's
examining here is the most important
part of philosophy right so there's a
prioritization
he says the motivation is not to learn
how to live well but to understand the
way the world works so we've got two
main and perhaps competing motivations
here they can't both
be on top and it's really tough to make
them
exactly equal or to integrate them
fully now sellers considers the
possibility that
maybe his position on aristotle here is
wrong or a little bit too one-sided
because pierre ado
himself has said that aristotle the
aristotelians
uh the lyceum are engaged in philosophy
as a way of life just not quite sit in
the same way
say as the stoics or socrates was
or you know the cynics and and so
sellers has to engage that and i think
that
quite frankly sellers is right on this
and ado is probably wrong
so he says that ado did his best to
subsume
aristotle under the banner of philosophy
as a way of life
by reminding us that the aristotelian
ideal of
theoria or contemplation theoretical
truth
is an activity that itself becomes a
lived practice
and so something that effectively
becomes a way of life and
that's quite true right theoria
is an action it's not action in the same
sense as political or moral action
let alone productive action but it is it
is a an
action and you do have to arrange your
life
in such a way that you would be able to
not just acquire the skills but be able
to engage
in that activity and aristotle does
think that's the best life
and if we do look at the lyceum his
school and its development afterwards
with like theo frostos and
you know lycos and all these other
people they seem to have followed that
course so there's something to that
but he goes on and he says hadou does
not deny that for aristotle the highest
form of theoretical knowledge is
something that's chosen for itself
it's true that the pursuit of
theoretical knowledge might itself form
a way of life
the claim that this form of life is the
motivating force for aristotle seems
less convincing what matters to
aristotle most of all is understanding
the word the way the world
works given that he will prefer a life
devoted to the pursuit of that kind of
understanding
over a life devoted to the pursuit of
anything else that doesn't mean
that the question of how best to live
was upper mind in his mind in the way
that it clearly was for socrates
so he does consider the best way to live
but that's not
it's not motivating him in the same way
and so then sellers says
well we do have to consider another
possible challenge as well
what about the fact that aristotle wrote
two books called the ethics the
nick of mccain and eudaimian ethics
where it's all about you know
practical life and the virtues and vices
and analysis of you know how
uh our faculty of choice works and
habits
you know he also considers happiness
okay and we could even make this tougher
and say not only does aristotle consider
those sort of questions in those two
ethics it's also in the politics
it's also in the rhetoric it's also in
the
po the poetics what we have of it in
book one
um you know comes up in the topics to
some degree and in book three
it comes up in some of the problems
there's a lot of connections to this
there's a robust you know moral
political rhetorical philosophy running
through aristotle
presumably he wouldn't have studied that
unless he was really interested in that
and we also know that aristotle
was very interested in communities and
how they worked
and studied a whole bunch of different
constitutions we only have one
of the many that he actually and his
students wrote together
theo frastus his his successor continued
that study
with um analyses of the legal
systems of all these different political
organizations in ancient greece
so there clearly was a practical aspect
right
um is this enough to get us what we want
is
philosophy as a way of life there's a
couple things to be said here
so sellers says um
in the opening book of the nick of
mccain ethics aristotle famously says
all human beings identify
you diamonia with living well but
later on in book 10 he prioritizes the
contemplative life
over other forms of life and he doesn't
do so based on its propensity to
generate eudaimonia but
rather on the superiority of its objects
of knowledge
unchanging universals rather than
changeable matters
the contemplative life is best not
because it is identified with living
well
but because it devotes itself to the
highest form of knowledge there is
and you know in a certain respect you
could say that
aristotle despite his insistences that
practical philosophy
is all about like doing things the right
way
when you look at the politics when you
look at the athenian constitution even
when you look at parts of the ethics
there's a lot of theorizing going on in
this
it's not just a manual like how to do
how to do things right and you know
understand yourself and make yourself a
better person there's a lot of
understanding things for the sake of
understanding these
human affairs and it becomes much more
theoretical
so you know arguably aristotle really
does fit into this
more scientific paradigm it's
interesting
this is not something that sellers
brings up but you notice that within
the hellenistic and later roman
cultural sphere where philosophy plays a
very important role
the aristotelians themselves don't play
that big of a role
you know compared to other schools like
the
academic skeptics and then the pyronian
skeptics as well
or the stoics or the epicureans or the
other platonists there are aristotelians
and they are
important but very often they're sort of
you know they're they're they they have
a reputation
but they're not the most important uh
and most attractive way of doing things
it could be because there's so much
emphasis
on the theoretical rather than the
practical
we can be blinded to that in part
because
in the anglo-sphere our
you know so-called revival of virtue
ethics which had never actually gone
away
was so closely connected with
neo-aristotelianism that we'd assume
that aristotle was like
the main game in town he wasn't
so you know i think sellers is actually
quite correct on this now what is the
upshot of this he's saying
all of this because this helps to
illuminate what
philosophy of as a way of life would be
and what it wouldn't be he says
we have a clear metaphysical division
between socrates and aristotle
both are committed to the pursuit of
knowledge both
offer an ideal of an image of an ideal
life involving the pursuit of knowledge
but there's a clear difference when we
turn to their ultimate motivations
socrates pursues knowledge in order to
live a philosophical life
while aristotle lives a philosophical
life in order to pursue
knowledge and sellers says this is a
subtle but i think important difference
i don't think it's actually that subtle
of a difference
this is quite in your face it's all and
he says it's also the difference between
what i call the scientific and
humanistic conceptions
of philosophy and
the subsequent history of western
philosophy has seen both of these
flourish at different times sometimes in
combination
sometimes apart and so
you know we see some philosophers
emphasizing this more there's kind of a
tradition and a continuity here
some people would think that philosophy
is really just the
scientific conception of philosophy some
movements of philosophy and they would
be divorced
from philosophy as a way of life
philosophy as a way of life is always
going to be more focused on this
humanistic conception that we see in
socrates but also in
cicero and petrarch and so many other
people down the centuries
you